alors de terminer le journal avant
surtout de passer à la bourse dans un
instant la visite en france d'un
extraordinaire personnage à paris un
chinois qui fait une série de
conférences sur la sculpture dans son
pays au musée guinée il s'agit de chang
souvenez-vous dans lotus bleu de tintin
le petit chinois s'était lui hergé a
construit ce personnage à partir de la
réalité à partir de l'homme qui est en
visite à paris en ce moment une histoire
très émouvante
claude crespo bernard plus haut si vous
avez entre 77 et 7 ans vous pouvez
mettre un nom sur tous ces visages à
droite l'un des héros du lotus bleu et
vassy ou non d'un second run est oui à
gauche c'est le véritable chang
actuellement en visite à paris
les tribulations de ce chinois en france
l'ont amené avec sa fille à visiter
cette exposition tente à thème fiction
et réalité à partir de l'album on a
marché sur la lune fiction-réalité ont
également scandé la collaboration de
tchang et hergé
elle remonte à cinquante ans hergé
travail sur le lotus bleu et chang natif
de shanghai est étudiant à bruxelles sûr
à sa caution d'authenticité
pendant un an ils passeront leur dit
mange ensemble et des milliers d ce qui
naîtront qui ressurgit dans sa mémoire
tandis qu'ils se laissent croquer le
portrait mais zhang refusera de cosigner
l'album avec hergé il a dit node est
encore plus fort jeudi c'est fait titre
dance mon en ce moment c'est mieux de
neuf ne signez pas je ne signe pas mais
il a dit enfin cocon quand même vous
devez signer à jeudi vie je signe
quelque part on attendait quand le
tessin tôt finie j'ai signé pétrole eh
bien j'ai signé dans quelques endroits
et après j'ai oublié
après en donne ici être laisser oublier
cette affaire
chang dans la saga hergé est un cas
unique
c'est le seul ami à peu près du même âge
que tintin alors là c'est l'histoire
d'une amitié qui va naître entre tintin
et chang une amitié très pure et qui
dans la vie de hergé d'ailleurs
correspond à une période où hergé disait
lui-même que c'était après une une sorte
de cure psychologique qu'il avait créé
cet album qui était un outil b dont on
sait qu'ils aient fait presque
uniquement en blanc et c'est un
véritable hymne à l'amitié dans lequel
il a repris un personnage qui avait déjà
existé dans le lotus bleu et qu'il a
réactualisé ce personnage et c'est
effectivement le seul véritable ami
qu'il ait eu au sens de l'amitié
aujourd'hui shangla 78 et s'il peut à
beaubourg confrontés sont passés de lait
trait aux réalités parfois obscur de
l'art contemporain
ce n'est pas l'ami de tintin qui est
fêtée mais bien un artiste qui fut
longtemps disgrâce pour cause de
révolution culturelle
quel est votre métier ces six sculpteurs
et est ce que vous pouvez exercer
librement votre métier en chine
oui cette main et son oeuvre c'est la
sienne quand il avait 25 ans c'est cette
main qui sim
un demi siècle plus tard des autographes
à des tintinophiles enragé
cet admirateur de jeux aquatiques a dû
plus une fois et prendre d'autres mains
celle d'hergé
c'est enfin cette main qui a scellé une
amitié indestructible
au delà des mots au delà même de la vie
à force de croire en des rêves l'homme
en fait une réalité